we will hear from larry durker and kevin
eschenfelder with their thoughts as we
reminisce about the life of jimmy winn
throughout the course of tonight's game
the toy cannon lost him in march 26th of
this year last time we saw christian
javier he was coming out of relief in
dodgers stadium gave a two solid inning
struck out five dodgers
on the season he has a very good
opponent batting average which also
helps keep that whip under one dalton
varshall
catching tonight and leading off he is
the first catcher in diamondbacks
history to battle leadoff
and a swing and a miss javier gets a
strike out of the first batter he faces
getting marshall to chase out of the
zone the one out of nobody on or josh
van meter some swings and misses here
another pitch that may have been out of
the zone up
hitters have a tough time laying off
that pitch from javier here's josh rojas
called third strike javier strikes out
this eye
starting pitcher luke weaver the
right-hander season high 93 pitches last
time out against the mariners went five
innings in that game did not give up a
home run that's kind of been an issue
for luke this year jose altuve will go
through his usual hysterics three and
two to jose altuve
got him with a fastball at 96 strikeout
number one for luke michael bradley the
left fielder
weaver knocks it down recovers
and a nice scoop at first by paving
smith there's your nice quick one two
three first for luke weaver
just the way dusty baker drew it up face
cole calhoun with nobody on base
he got a fastball did he get enough call
calhoun
oh my goodness kidding me wow
[Applause]
cole calhoun diamondback strike first in
houston that's six home runs in five
games on this trip one-nothing
diamondbacks
jazz roberts air conditioning and
plumbing cool play of the game any time
cole calhoun comes to the plate recently
it's been a cool play
towering home run this time well back
into the bleachers in right field and
alex bregman leads off the houston
second
we're gonna miss it gets to the backstop
marshall hustles back there what a
tremendous play by dalton varsha to go
get that one that seemed almost certain
that bregman was going to reach first
tremendous hustle by dalton varshall
right there now the answers probably
bring the infield in with one out the
hitter will be rojas who struck out
looking on a 3-2 pitch in the first
inning 2-2 on the way
josh reaches out and pokes it to center
springer is there
and here comes dalton varshall
as you said get him on get them over and
they get them in it's two-nothing
diamondbacks so not much of a threat to
run here's eduardo escobar now
dropped in the breaking ball for the
called third strike nice job by javier
that'll put runners on first and third
with one away a chance for jose altuve
on the ground slowly hit towards third
escobar to second for one altuve beats
the relay astro score their first run
crossing the play it is josh reddick and
it's now a two-to-one game
david peralta will lead off in the
fourth inning and xavier dots up the
outside corner peralta threw the bat
away but now he can go pick it up on his
way back to the dugout that is strikeout
number five for javier matheson walked
his first time up swing and a miss
javier gets him on the slider maldonado
will make the tag two strikeouts in the
inning six strikeouts in the game stays
2-1 josh reddick has the astros only hit
against luke weaver single in the third
fastball right down the middle reddick
missed it and luke weaver has his third
strikeout down for maldonado who as bob
mentioned through that walk in the third
the only walk issued by luke so far
there's a swing through that fastball
four strikeouts for luke he's through
five with a 2-1 lead
that is george springer leads off and
sends one into center field coming in is
john jay still coming in george happy
birthday a little flare signal in the
center thumbs up right there for george
they say don't meet your heroes because
you'll always be disappointed and jimmy
winn never did
and we've got jose altuve at the plate
right now small in stature but big on
the field as we see some jimmy win
memories with eschenfelder got the
headsets on i think he had to be i mean
uh here's let you guys take care of some
business right here because i think
we're just about to tie this thing up
george springer rounding third on the
altuve double we're tied at two jose
altuve at rbi double ties it up altuve's
second double in his many games
and he has both runs batted in tonight
for the astros
and here is alex breitbart for two
waves at a good change up there and
weaver gets strikeout number five so now
it's up to kyle tucker
and a line driving a left center field
that'll be down for a base hit altuve
can walk home rbi number 41 on the year
for kyle tucker and the astros take a
3-2 lead
john jay has flied out and also grounded
out
and a line drive towards left brantley
is there he makes the play throw to
second double play michael bradley
the double play turn on a strike to jose
altuve as they get pavon smith leading
off second
swing and a miss pressley gets that
chase on the slider the ball game is
over the astros win it 3-2
they have reduced their magic number
down to five to clinch a playoff spot
and they have now split the first two
games of this three-game series with the
arizona diamondbacks back to 500 plummer
at 26 and 26. they needed this win